attack that queen with this rook  surprising move from anish there  and after the black queen moves has to  retreat  and defend its rook  magnus might just take another pawn a  third pawn is about to drop  that very far advanced black pawn he can  take it but no he goes for the black  queen with his knight magnus all out  attack here focused on the black king  and okay anish giving back some material  so now we have a situation where it's  queen against two rooks but it will all  hinge on king's safety and just look how  shaky the black king is  and also let's not forget that white his  material up yeah this is the second game  in a row both of their blitz games that  anish has a weak king and that weak king  means he cannot avoid the checks it's a  draw magnus carlsen takes today's match  will we see a handshake between them or  are they simply just immediately start  discussing their games magnus carlsen is  the winner in this match gaining two  points